I'll put it this way when Jesse Smollett
comes out and claims some guys threw a
noose around his neck the whole world
shuts down every television network runs
a tribute you get uh at the time Alan
Page saying
like frantically randomly because some
guy hate crime hoaxed all of us
and then when you get a story about a
GOP lawyer being stabbed to death it's
like well you know we don't know exactly
so let's move on from this that's why I
think the story matters because maybe
people on the right be it post-liberal
libertarian whatever you want to call
yourself should start saying when these
things happen we make the Assumption in
the worst until we learn otherwise
because they went balls to the wall for
Jesse Smollett so how about we say we
demand answers as to what happened to
this GOP lawyer who got stabbed to death
in his own home the police are claiming
was self-defense